bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat hier soir lors de
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à la
modernisation du système de santé
les sénateurs ont étendu le dispositif
de droit à l'oubli bancaire pour les
anciens malades du cancer
aujourd'hui une personne guéri du cancer
n'est pas une personne comme les autres
aux yeux de son assurance concrètement
si elle veut emprunter de l'argent
l'assurance de ce prêt peut être jusqu'à
200 % plus élevé que la moyenne en 2014
avec le plan cancer fra saur françois
hollande avait promis qu'au bout d'un
certain nombre d'années les personnes
guéries du concert devait devenir des
personnes comme les autres qu'elle ne
devait plus être obligé de déclarer
cette ancienne maladie et devait avoir
les mêmes conditions d'emprunt que le
reste de la population
le projet de loi de marisol touraine
certes ne va pas aussi loin que la
promesse de françois hollande
mais hier des amendements sénatoriaux
ont permis d'étendre ce dispositif pour
que plus denses à malades soient
concernés plus vite
regardez article 46 bis j'ai une demande
de parole de monsieur watrin vous avez
la parole vous chers collègues
merci en france le code pénal art et
c'est un constat autorise une seule
discrimination aux assurances c'est
celle sur l'état de santé
en clair pour obtenir un prêt dans une
blanche il faut souscrire à une
assurance qui est censé prendre le
relais du remboursement cas de décès ou
d'invalidité or si l'on souffre d'une
maladie au long cours que l'on a été
malade dans sa vie les assureurs
considèrent que ce risque est multiplié
les surprimes s'accumulent devant les
plaintes répétées des associations de
plaques patients et notamment l'action
très déterminé des malades du cancer un
nouveau protocole d'accord vient d'être
signé dans le cadre de la convention
aereas cet accord est censée faciliter
l'accès du prêt pour les anciens malades
atteints de cancer hélas malgré les
promesses du plan cancer 3 et tous les
efforts l'institut national du cancer
linka pour faire aboutir au mieux les
négociations cette nouvelle
convention est en-deça des attentes des
malades des associations mais aussi des
acteurs de la santé qui se battent
chaque jour pour donner un avenir leurs
patients le droit d'oublier reconnu
seulement pour les quatre concerts et
encore de manière restrictive en parle
donc des personnes ayant eu un cas ce
cancer avant l'âge de 15 ans totalement
guéri qui ne suivent plus aucun
traitement depuis cinq ans sont
également concernées les personnes
touchées par un cancer l'âge adulte mais
guéridon le dernier traitement remonte à
plus de 15 ans mais si vous avez eu un
cancer du sein à 35 ans par exemple ce
qui touche hélas de nombreuses femmes
vous êtes exclu du dispositif un âge où
vous pourriez avoir besoin d'emprunter
l'ufc que choisir qui a eu accès un
certain nombre de données l'air et as
parle de 60 % de marge pour les
assureurs dans le domaine des risques
médicaux aggravé assurer les malades et
un secteur il faut le dire lucratif ou
les assurances font énormément de
bénéfices non seulement les assureurs
surtaxe mais en plus il ya très peu de
versement d'indemnités nous demandons
donc à ce que cette convention qui se
révèle trop peu contraignantes pour les
assureurs est en décalage par rapport
aux progrès de la médecine se voir
encadré par le législateur dans le cadre
du projet de loi santé il faut enfin que
soit rapidement mis en place comme
l'avait promis solennellement le
président de la république un véritable
droit à l'oubli non seulement pour les
enfants mais aussi pour les adolescents
les adultes guéri cinq ans après la fin
de leur traitement
merci monsieur watrin je suis saisi le
24 amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
nous commençons par le 24 et eefje terre
madame micouleau madame la présidente
madame la ministre cet amendement
propose d'étendre le droit à l'oubli
pour les organismes d'assurance et les
banques à toutes les personnes guéries
d'un cancer dont la guérison est
constatée entre
son dépôt un examen et son examen en
séance est intervenue le 2 septembre
dernier un avenant à la convention aéras
ce cet avenant est en-deça des attentes
des malades des associations mais aussi
des acteurs de la santé qui se battent
au quotidien pour donner un avenir à
leur passion cet avenant n'est
véritablement pas non plus à la hauteur
des promesses du plan cancer 3 c'est la
raison pour laquelle je retire cet
amendement un retrait au profit des
amendements qui suivent notamment le 136
et les suivants qui ont été déposées par
mes collègues cayeux et gruny compte
tenu de cette convention aéras ce
réviser ces amendements présente un
effet le mérite de parfaitement répondre
et de manière complète à la question
majeure pour nous qu'on s'y arrête pour
nos concitoyens
celle du droit à l'oubli merci madame
micouleau pardonnez moi mais vous
retirer votre amendement au profit du
136 nous en 36 s'étaient retirés donc le
137 peut-être un seul et suivant le
137,1 d'accord très vite nous passons
donc aux 137 rectifié vi madame cayeux
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous
entrons donc dans un certain nombre de
délibérations concernent d'amendements
concernant le droit à l'oubli
j'ai bien entendu madame la ministre les
précisions que vous nous avez apporté
concernant la signature récente de la
d'un article supplémentaire à la
convention initiale de février mais un
certain nombre de précisions
souhaiterait serait importante à prendre
alors cet amendement vise à préciser les
délais définis par cette convention au
delà desquels le droit à l'oubli
intégral est accordée aux anciens
malades de cancer c'est à dire plus
précisément sans obligation de
déclaration de la pathologie à
l'organisme d'assurance lors de la
souscription d'un prêt bancaire
alors je reviens sur les différents
délais premièrement il fixe le délai
maximum pour accorder le droit à l'oubli
pour les pathologies cancéreuses à 10
ans et non plus à 15 ans comme le
prévoit à l'avenant signé le 2 septembre
dernier
en effet ce délai de 15 ans ne repose à
ce jour sur aucun fondement scientifique
deuxièmement l'amendement vise aussi à
accorder à l'ensemble des mineurs le
droit à l'oubli cinq ans au maximum
après la fin des traitements et ainsi
qu'à tous les autres malades dont les
données de la science nous disent qu'ils
sont définitivement guéri troisièmement
enfin au nom du principe d'égalité des
droits
le présent amendement propose d'étendre
ce droit à l'oubli intégral à 5 ans aux
personnes de plus de 18 ans pour
lesquels le taux global de survie à 5
ans par pathologie est comparable à
celui des enfants et des adolescents
enfin il est proposé de prévoir un
décret d'application afin de veiller
d'une part à ce que les questionnaires
médicaux que les candidats emprunteurs
doivent remplir garantit ce droit à
l'oubli et que d'autre part ces derniers
soient informés des nouvelles
dispositions de la convention aéras ce
merci madame cayeux amendement 549
madame eugénie sens oui merci madame la
présidente et à mon tour après madame le
rapporteur et madame la ministre
me féliciter au nom de mon groupe de ce
nouveau droit fondamental que le droit à
l'oubli est souligné dans l'article
dans cet article des finissants
l'importance de l'alinéa 3 qui a dit que
ses modalités et ses traitements aient
cédé les parts contre pardon sans mis à
jour régulièrement en fonction des
progrès thérapeutiques je crois que
c'est très important
cet alinéa est très important a rappelé
je défendrai mon amendement l'amendement
vise à préciser les défis les délais
définis par la convention ars au delà
desquels le droit à l'oubli intégral est
accordée aux anciens malades de cancer
c'est à dire sans obligation de
déclaration de la pathologie est
l'organisme d'assurance lors de la
souscription d'un prêt bancaire
cela vient d'être précisée premièrement
il fixe le délai maximum pour accorder
le droit à l'oubli pour les pathologies
cancéreuses à 10 ans et non plus à 15
ans comme le prévoit la loi signée le 2
septembre dernier
en effet une semble pas qu'il y ait de
comment dire de fondement scientifique à
l'exigence de ce délai de 15 ans
deuxièmement l'amendement vise à
accorder à l'ensemble des mineurs le
droit à l'oubli cinq ans maximum après
la fin des traitements
s'il maintient ce il matérialise une
avancée significative en prévoyant un
droit à l'oubli pour les moins de 15 ans
cinq ans après la date de la fin des
traitements
l'avenant du 2 septembre exclu du
dispositif les jeunes ayant contracté
une pathologie cancéreuse entre 15 et 18
ans et ce sans aucune justification
d'ordre médical et tico juridique
or enfants et adolescents présentent des
taux de survie comparables de plus de
90% selon l'institut selon l'étude
pardon de l'institut national du cancer
de janvier 2015 les 15 18 ans ne
représentent en outre que 800 cas
nouveaux parents troisièmement au nom du
principe d'égalité des droits le présent
amendement propose d'étendre ce droit à
l'oubli intégral à 5 ans aux personnes
de plus de 18 ans pour lesquels les taux
global de survie à 5 ans par pathologie
comparable à celui des enfants et
adolescents
enfin il est proposé de prévoir un
décret d'application afin de veiller
d'une part à ce que le questionnaire
médicaux que les candidats emprunteurs
doivent remplir garantissent le droit à
l'oubli et que d'autre part ces derniers
soit informé des nouvelles dispositions
de la convention aéras ce merci
amendement 608 rectifié lice madame
guyon
merci madame la présidente donc c'est
exactement le même amendement que celui
de mes collègues
mesdames cayeux et génie sont donc je
vais vous éviter un troisième
argumentaire il est défendu merci merci
l'amendement 820 madame cohen oui je
rejoins ce que mes collègues on dit je
trouve que l'article que nous examinions
répond vraiment à une très très forte
demande de nombreux patients et
notamment les malades atteints du cancer
et on assiste donc à un nouveau droit
l'ouverture d'un nouveau droit le droit
à l'oubli c'est une promesse qui avait
été faite par le président françois
hollande lors de de l'annnonce du plan
cancer en février 2014
et ça constitue comme ça qu'est souligné
pour le groupe sert c'est une avancée
importante les convention conclue entre
l'état les associations de malades ou
les personnes handicapées les
professionnels de l'assurance pourront
déterminer les délais au delà desquels
les personnes ayant souffert d'un cancer
ne peuvent se voir appliquer d'exclusion
de garantie ni de majoration de tarifs
donc notre belle notre amendements comme
celui de puisque c'est le même
deux de nos collègues revient sur les
délais fixés par la convention signée le
2 septembre dernier
d'abord il est proposé de fixer le délai
maximum pour accorder le droit à l'oubli
pour les pathologies cancéreuses et 10
ans au lieu de 15 ans je crois que c'est
ce qui correspond vraiment davantage à
la réalité
nous avons quand même des études sur le
taux de survie des personnes atteintes
de concerts qu de cancer qui font de
leurs estimations à cinq voire dix ans
et conclut que les récidives surviennent
le plus souvent dans les premières
années que deuxièmement notre amendement
vise à accorder à l'ensemble des mineurs
le droit à l'oubli cinq ans maximum
après la fin des traitements
en effet le protocole d'accord prévoit
ce délai uniquement pour les moins de 15
ans excluant de fait les mineurs âgés de
15 ans à 18 ans et je crois qu'il ya
aucune explication d'ordre médical
éthique ou juridique qui ne justifie
cette limite d'âge et vous avez
certainement reçu comme nous au niveau
du groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen de nombreux témoignages
qui nous pressent vraiment d'améliorer
encore les choses qui ont été obtenues
et qui sont contenues dans ce projet de
loi et troisièmement nom du principe
d'égalité des droits
le présent amendement propose d'étendre
ce droit à l'oubli intégral à 5 ans aux
personnes pour lesquelles le taux global
de survie à 5 ans par pathologie est
comparable à celui des enfants et
adolescents et enfin il est aussi
proposé donc un décret d'application
je crois vraiment il faut entendre ce
que nous disent les associations de
patients et répondra à leurs attentes
qui est vraiment tout à fait justifié
merci van quan l'amendement 891 rectifié
madame laborde
oui merci madame la présidente donc je
ne vais pas vous imposer une énième
argumentation pour un amendement
identique
j'ai simplement apprécier le propos
liminaire de la rapporteure et de madame
la ministre pour dire que bien sûr en
fonction de l'évolution des maladies et
donc de notre avancée scientifique les
choses seraient revus merci madame à
archambault
oui rapidement il est fâcheux pense
qu'il faut souligner que l'introduction
dans ce cas enfin la présence dans cette
loi de la reconnaissance de nouveaux
droits le droit à l'oubli qui avait été
promis sur lequel s'est engagé le
président la république est un progrès
considérable et qu'il faut évidemment le
le souligner alors cet amendement permet
enfin pourrait permettre d'aller un peu
plus loin je ne vais pas le présenter à
mon tour vous là vous avez déjà entendu
les entendu les arguments
c'est une question très sensible parce
qu'elle cause elles concernent dans
notre pays un un très grand nombre de
deux de nos concitoyens que citoyenne
donc c'est vrai que je pense important
que le parlement sur cette question
appuyez appuyé les propositions du
gouvernement et et pousse dans un sens
qui permet d'être vraiment faim de les
favoriser la réinsertion de toutes ces
personnes dans la soute et j'insiste sur
le décret enfin je veux souligner moi
l'important son petit du décret
d'application qui est qui figure à la
fin de set
cet amendement qui est proposé d'une
part un décret d'application afin de
veiller du pince les questionnaires
médicaux que les candidats emprunteurs
doivent remplir garantit ce droit à
l'oubli sur tous les questionnaires qui
sont posés par les banques
ou alors parlé par les assurances et
c'est vrai que ça provoque ça provoque
des difficultés en chaîne merci madame
archambault nous passons maintenant à
l'amendement 138 rectifié bis madame
cayeux
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre cet amendement en fait traite
le délai au-delà duquel aucune
information médicale ne saurait être
recueilli par les organismes assureurs
et ne pourront excéder dix ans après la
date de fin de protocole thérapeutique
défini par l'institut national du cancer
rien ne justifiant donc d'attendre
quinze ans pour accorder à droit à
l'oubli si madame cayeux le 609 rectifié
bis qui va être sous tes pas mal bu un
bisou à la parole oui madame la
présidente madame la ministre donc comme
tout à leur amendement identique à celui
de madame cayeux le 138 rectifié bis
donc défendu merci madame millions 1936
c'est identique ou à la marche un beau
défendu je vous remercie le 139 rectifié
madame cayeux
vous madame la présidente madame la
ministre cet amendement vise à étendre à
l'ensemble des mineurs le dispositif du
droit à l'oubli
l'avenant qui a été signé et dont à fait
état madame la ministre le 2 septembre
dernier par les membres de la convention
areas a certes matérialiser des avancées
significatives mais reste bien en-deça
des promesses qui avaient été faites par
le président de la république lors de
l'annoncé du plan cancer 3 donc sans
justification d'ordre médical et éthique
ou juridique il exclut les jeunes ayant
contracté une pathologie cancéreuse
entre 15 et 18 ans du dispositif adopté
pour les moins de 15 ans en outre c'est
une représente que 800 nouveaux cas par
an avec des taux de survie de plus de 80
2% selon l'étude de l'institut national
du cancer et leurs risques très relatif
peut donc être mutualisés par les
organismes assureurs sur l'ensemble des
emprunteurs merci madame cayeux le 566
sur vos imprimés ce rachat
oui c'est pratiquement le même
amendement d'ailleurs se pourrir
simplement une question et répond madame
la ministre et qui nous paraît
incompréhensible que le droit à l'oubli
s'arrête à l'âge de 15 ha et que ça ne
couvre pas jusqu'à 18 ans c'est à dire
tous les mineurs ceci me paraît d'autant
plus incompréhensible qu entre 15 et 18
ans le nombre de cancers annuel est à
peu près évalué à 800 par an avec un
taux de guérison 82% c'est à dire que le
risque pour l'heure pour l'assureur est
très mais très petit donc on attend un
peu les explications parce que ça nous
est tout seul
cette discrimination entre les 15 et 18
ans nous étonne merci madame billon le
610 rectifié vis c'est identique
défendue je vous remercie madame laborde
le 892 rectifié identique hors identique
mêmes questionnements
merci merci madame laborde le 937
identique aussi madame archambault oui
oui absolument identique donc défendu je
vous remercie le 140 rectifié terre
madame cayeux défendu le 611 rectifié
bis ce madame billon défendu le 938
madame archambault défendu je vous
remercie le 141 rectifié vis madame
cayeux
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre
en fait dans cette dans ce texte nous
proposons d'insérer deux alinéas
supplémentaires après l'alinéa 2 pour
qu' il y est un décret en conseil d'état
qui détermine les informations médicales
qui peuvent être demandées dans le cadre
du formulaire de déclaration de risque
mentionnés aux articles l 113 2 du code
des assurances l 221 13 du code de la
mutualité et l 932 5 du code de la
sécurité sociale afin de garantir le
respect des droits définis par le
présent article
un décret définit les modalités
d'information des candidats à l'emprunt
relatives aux dispositions du présent
article merci 1939 à damas chambaud qui
est identique
oui il est identique et pour compléter
ce que vient de dire mes collègues c'est
vrai que il est il est proposé que les
questionnaires de santé que les
candidats à l'emprunt doivent remplir ne
comporte pas de question ambiguë et que
ces derniers par ailleurs soit informée
au préalable de ces nouveaux droits
merci le 821
madame cohen madame david oui merci
madame la présidente
cet amendement vous l'aurez compris est
un amendement en repli par rapport à
celui que nous avons défendues
précédemment puisqu'il ne s'agit plus de
fixer des délais pour les conventions
mais de se concentrer plutôt sur deux
points
premièrement le formulaire de
déclaration des risques établi par les
organismes assureurs afin de faire du
droit à l'oubli une réalité il est
important de déterminer par décret et
avec précision les informations qui
peuvent être demandés et la manière dont
elles le sont ainsi il convient de
s'assurer que la non déclaration est
respectée et que les questionnaires ne
comporte pas de question ambiguë
enfin il s'agit de garantir aux
personnes concernées une information
fiable sur ces nouveaux droits sans quoi
ils ne seront pas mises en oeuvre
deuxièmement le présent le présent
amendement rappelle les obligations des
organismes assureurs en effet ils
doivent d'une part respecter les
conclusions des études menées dans le
cadre de l'instance de suivi et de
propositions dont nous avons déjà parlé
d'autre part ils doivent respecter les
délais définis par la grille de
référence établi par ladite instance
il est également prévu de définir des
sanctions en cas de non-respect de ces
obligations pour un véritable droit à
l'oubli donc pour ces anciens malades
il est donc important de s'assurer que
cette déclaration soit rempli
correctement
merci madame david le 143 rectifié de
terre madame cayeux
oui madame la présidente l'objet de cet
amendement est de queuleu le droit à
l'oubli soit gars entier et qu'il paraît
donc indispensable que les assureurs
s'engagent à respecter les nouveaux
délais fixés par la commission des
études et recherche institué par la
convention aéras ce or jusqu'à présent
le texte de cette convention précise
simplement que les assureurs tiennent
compte des études produites par cette
commission pour le calcul des primes et
exclusion des garanties le présent
amendement vise donc à inscrire dans la
loi l'obligation pour ces derniers de
respecter les nouveaux délais définis et
prévoit un décret d'application pour
définir les sanctions en cas de
manquement à cette obligation
merci le 893 rectifié madame laborde est
donc toujours dans la même lignée
simplement pour ne pas oublier de
s'occuper des anciens
malade qui ont le droit de retrouver
toute leur place dans la société et ne
plus subir la double peine la maladie et
l'après maladie donc il faut faire un
certain nombre d'efforts pour que ça
puisse s'arranger
merci madame archambault 1941
c'est exactement le même amendement que
celui qui a été défendu par madame
cayeux avec les mêmes les mêmes
observations emma chers collègues je
vais maintenant demander l'avis de la
commission sur ces amendements
alors comme je lai indiqué
en préalable la commission sur tous les
amendements concernant cet article
donner un avis de sagesse alors
néanmoins concernant la maman 137
rectifié bis 549 608 lui 120 891 1935
qui sont des amendements identiques donc
ces amendements visent à inscrire dans
la loi des paramètres aujourd'hui fixés
par la négociation et à modifier les
paramètres tels tels qu'ils sont dans
l'accord signé le le 2 septembre dernier
il ya un point que je voulais quand même
noter c'est que le délai de quinze ans
après l'arrêt des traitements pour
l'ouverture du droit à l'oubli constitue
un maximum qui devraient être abaissés
pathologie par pathologie en fonction
des progrès de la médecine
une première grille de référence doit
être élaboré avant la fin de l'année
deux 2005 et est à mes yeux le semble
que cette méthode est peut-être
préférable à l'utilisation d'un taux
global de survie qui ne saurait réfléter
qu'imparfaitement le risque réellement
porté par les candidats à l'assurance
mais non moins saint avit sagesse selon
l'avis de la commission sur les
abonnements suivant 138 rectifié bis lé
le 609 rectifier et oh là là et 46 bis
identique à vis de sagesse également
j'essayais de me retrouver sur les 139
rectifié de terre 566 610 rectifié vis
892 rectifié 937 qui sont identiques
là c'est un droit à l'oubli pour les
cancers survenus à l'âge de 18 ans et
non plus 15 ans comme c'est dans le
texte mais il me semble qu'en effet
c'est un sujet important et la c1
un avis de sagesse favorable dans la
mesure où c'est vrai lorsqu'on entend
toutes les les jeunes qui sont qui ont
été atteints d'un cancer dans leur
enfance ou adolescence les difficultés
après pour se projeter dans l'avenir
sont importantes et et l'a servi de
sagesse mais favorable positive plus ou
moins alors le 140 rectifié terre 611
rectifié bis rectifié bis et s'il 938
rectifié toujours avide sagesse on
remarque particulière alors le 141 à
rectifier bis et le 939 rectifier donc
ceux qui sont les mêmes la donc la
convention se borne à indiquer que
certaines informations ne pourront plus
être demandé le président les
amendements propose d'indiquer d'un
décret la nature des informations qui
pourront être demandés
bon l'engagement pris par les parties
avait été de 2 pouvait apparaître
suffisant s'il était respecté été
inspectés à garantir le droit à l'oubli
sans qu'il soit nécessaire de fixer une
manière exhaustif la liste des
informations qui peuvent être demandés
il ya un point simplement c'est qu'un
tel décret pourrait être incompatible
avec l'article l113 direct du code des
assurances qui oblige les candidats sur
ans à répondre avec exactitude aux
questions qui leur sont posées mais
toujours à vis de sagesse 821 143
rectifié terre bah ça c'est le même en
fait ils combinent un peu les
dispositions des amendements précédents
mais c'est le même avis 143 rectifié
terre opposabilité des conclusions des
études menées par l'instance de suivi et
de propositions de la convention aéras
ce le la rédaction pose problème
néanmoins puisque la commission des
études et recherches visé par
l'amendement ne sont pas mentionnées
dans le code de la santé publique
donc avis de sagesse le 893 rectifié 941
c'était les mêmes sans nom oui c'était
les mêmes donc même avis le 140 de
rectifier terre et toi c'est tout bon
c'est fini
merci madame le rapporteur madame la
ministre à vis du gouvernement sur ces
24 amendements si vous oui madame la
présidente donc la première série
d'amendements sont 37 549 6 en 8 820 891
935 sont des amendements globaux qui
ensuite vont être déclinés thème par
thème donc je vais je donne un avis
défavorable à ces amendements comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire nous ne
disposons pas des bases scientifiques
pour ramener la durée du droit à l'oubli
systématiquement de 15 à 10 ans de la
même manière évoqué un taux de survie au
moins égal à celui des cancers
pédiatriques est une formulation
extrêmement flou parce que il n'ya pas
un taux de survie moyen il y a des taux
de survie moyen pathologie par
pathologie catégorie de cancer par
catégorie de cancer si on a un cancer
pas si on parle d'un cancer du sein d'un
cancer du foie d'un cancer des poumons
on a à chaque du pancréas soir on a à
chaque fois des taux de survie moyen qui
sont extraordinairement différents et
donc la formulation n'apparaît pas
scientifiquement fondées enfin pour ce
qui est de du décret qui permettrait que
vous souhaiter pour encadrer des
informations pouvant figurer dans la
convention 20 ans qui est figuré sur le
questionnaire c'est un peu paradoxal
parce que l'idée est précisément que le
questionnaire soit rédigée et qu'on
puisse ne pas cocher la case demandant
si on est malade dès lors qu'ils aient
un droit à l'oubli donc là le simple
fait de dire qu'il faut encadrer la
manière dont on va poser la question à
quelqu'un qui doit pouvoir bénéficier du
droit à l'oubli est un peu un peu
étonnante donc voilà donc j'ai indiqué
les trois points sur lesquels j'ai
disons je ne suis pas en mesure de
donner un avis favorable j'amènerai dans
un instant et donc je donne
un avis défavorable cette série
d'amendements logiquement je donne un
avis défavorable aux amendements 138
rectifié by 609 rectifié bis et 936 qui
vise à ramener la durée du droit à
l'oubli de 15 à 10 ans c'est ce que je
vous indiquais il y un instant sur
l'absence de données scientifiques
j'insiste sur le fait que l'institut
national de lutte contre le cancer qui
est très active et est très en faveur du
droit à l'oubli et qui travaille
beaucoup pour lui donner une
concrétisation dit qu' il n'est pas
actuellement en mesure de documenter
comme on dit scientifiquement cette
partie de face et ces éléments ou ses
amendements
en revanche les amendements 139 rectifié
terre 566 610 rectifié 1892 rectifier et
937 propose d'élargir la notion de
cancers pédiatriques à tous les cancers
survenus avant l'âge de 18 ans comme je
les indiquer est là parce que nous
disposons de données scientifiques qui
permettent de réduire l'incertitude au
maximum je donne un avis de sagesse un
avis de sagesse parce que je ne peux pas
affirmer que nous avons des données qui
permettent de garantir absolument ce qui
est souhaité néanmoins il y a là une
possibilité d'avancer donc c'est vous
l'entendez une sagesse très favorable
140 rectifié terre 611 rectifié 1938
gelé indiqué c'est là que l'on fait
référence aux pathologies cancéreuses à
taux de survie comparables j'ai dit tout
à l'heure la raison pour laquelle cela
ne me paraissait pas possible 141
rectifié 1939 il s'agit d'encadrer par
un décret des informations pouvant
figurer sur les questionnaires médicaux
j'ai également indiquer pourquoi cela me
paraissait un peu contradictoire
l'amendement 821
là encore avis défavorable puisqu'il
renvoie à la question des questionnaires
enfin 143 rectifié terre 983 rectifié
les signataires s'engagent et c'est
nouveau dans ces amendements
il s'agit d'inscrire dans la loi
l'obligation pour les organismes
assureurs de respecter les conclusions
de la commission études et recherche
ainsi que les délais prévus par la
grille de référence
mais les signataires s'engagent et à
partir du moment où il ya un contrat une
convention en l'occurrence il y a des
engagements qui sont pris et le non
respect d'engagements pris par la voie
contractuelle peuvent être sanctionné le
fait que nous votions le principe du
droit à l'oubli dans le cadre de la loi
permettra évidemment d'exercer des
pressions en direction des des assureurs
mais donc il ne me paraît pas nécessaire
d'entrer davantage dans le détail au
niveau de la loi donc avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nous allons donc passer au
vote de ces amendements
je vais donc prendre la première série
d'amendements donc le 137 rectifié vis
de 549 le 608 rectifié bis 820 et le 891
935 qui sont donc identiques avec un
avis de sagesse de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement
il y avait des explications de vote
monsieur vasselle il met dans la
présidente merci après l'examen de ces
différents amendements et avoir
recueilli l'avis à la fois du rapporteur
et du gouvernement constate que le
rapporteur n'a pas émis un avis par les
amendements sur l'âge
de 18 ans pour ce qui concerne les
mineurs ou l'ami un avis de sagesse
plutôt positif voire favorable sur les
autres il ya une certaine réticence à
aller jusqu'à un avis favorable sur
l'ensemble des amendements
donc la commission ne m'a pas paru très
à l'aise sur ce dossier et je puis
comprendre qu'elle ne le soit pas
totalement content du fait que l'avenant
a été si dire dadu dans sept ans l'encré
est à peine sèche que l'on décide déjà
de légiférer en considérant que la
convention de semer trépan
d'applications que l'on douteraient de
la part de ces acteurs qu'ils agiraient
dans le sens pour sur lequel ils se sont
dans lequel se sont engagés donc ça nous
met quand même nous les initiateurs dans
une situation un peu difficile parce
qu'il faudrait pas non plus que par
d'autres votes 12 et frémion un acte de
défiance à l'égard de ceux qui se sont
engagés et puis un autre problème c'est
à partir du moment où on va instaurer
des contraintes assez forte par la loi
les initiatives
qu'est ce qu'il en sera demain si on
demandait aux assureurs d'aller plus
loin dans le dispositif que nous
souhaitons et est-ce que économiquement
ce site deviendra supportable à la fois
par les compagnies d'assurances même si
à des réassurances est ce qu'on va pas
se retrouver avec des cotisations
d'assurance qui vont être beaucoup plus
importante que ne l'aurait été si on
respecter l'esprit et la lettre de la
convention donc pour conclure je ne sais
pas trop dans quelle direction je vais
m'engager
ceci étant je comprends tout à fait et
je partage l'objectif des auteurs de des
amendements parce que il y à une attente
très forte de la part de nos concitoyens
je trouve que nous avons beaucoup trop
tardé pour légiférer en la matière ou
pour s'engager dans une négociation
qu'on veut ce d'être pour aboutir au
résultat que nous espérons et cette
impatience
a été amendée vie à l'origine du dépôt
de tous ses amendements qui sont pour
origine de l'ensemble pratiquement
l'ensemble des groupes de la haute
assemblée dont je pense qu'effectivement
que le cdh a dans toute sa sagesse saura
prendre la décision qui s'impose
merci monsieur vasselle madame eugénie
son frein explications de vote
oui c'est vrai que nous sommes dans une
situation un peu difficile à la fois le
constat positif de l'existence de cette
convention de la création de ce droit à
l'oubli et en même temps la volonté
d'aller le plus loin possible et avec
quand même le souci comme vient de le
dire monsieur vasselle de paca c'est
comment dire là là le contenu d'une
convention qui vient d'être signée qui
pourrait finalement faire s'interroger
les signataires sur la volonté qu'elles
qu'elles aboutissent donc je rappelle
comme je l'avais dit au début de mon
propos qui a quand même l'alinéa 3 de
l'arc de l'article qui est précise bien
que en fonction des progrès
thérapeutiques
on pourra faire varier les délais de
régulièrement les délais de mises à jour
ça c'est une chose soit que c'est très
important mais madame aime initial ya un
sujet qui nous interpelle c'est que nous
faisons référence aux travaux de la cac
qui sont quand même là comment dire
notre bible en matière de de
cancérologie je pense et kiki sur le
sujet du délai de 15 ans ne semble pas
conforté comment dire la validité de ce
délai de 15 ans dans la mesure où en
fait les récidives surviennent souvent
dans les premières années faisant du
taux de survie à 5 ans voire à 10 ans
des estimations flap fiable bardot de la
probabilité de guérison des cancers et
au delà des dix ans le risque résiduel
étant stables plus aucune étude de
risque n'a été menée jusqu'à présent et
que on s'interroge quand même sur ce je
souhaiterais avoir votre amie madame la
ministre sur la
le pourquoi de sans doute au nom du
devoir de précaution a été institué ce
délai de 15 ans qui semble quand même
scientifiquement ne pas répondre à
comment dire des données précise madame
génisson madame canayer pour
l'explication de vote
oui madame la présidente madame la miss
mes chers collègues
effectivement le droit à l'oubli est un
droit de l'homme et c'est une avancée
fondamentale que de la reconnaissance de
ce droit dans la loi mais la loi est là
pour fixer l'exercice des libertés
fondamentales et des droits de l'homme
et je pense que il est important et
essentiel que la loi fixe un socle de
base concernant la reconnaissance de ce
droit à l'oubli
certes il y à des conventions il y a eu
des accords simplement ces conventions
et ses accords n'engagent que ceux qui
les signent dans ça n'engage que les
parties aux conventions et rien
n'interdit à ces conventions d'aller
plus loin mais dans le respect et de ce
que fixe la loi et c'est pour ça qu'à
mon avis il est fondamental que la loi
fixe la base et fixe le socle de ce
droit à l'oubli et d'exercice de ce
droit à l'oubli
d'autant qu'aujourd'hui la science
avance plus de 80% des cancers un taux
de survie supérieur à 5 ans et il est
fondamental que ce droit à l'oubli ra
quo soit raccourci pour être en
adéquation avec les progrès
scientifiques
pourquoi moi je pars je voterai
l'ensemble des amendements qui fixe une
avancée un progrès concernant ce droit à
l'oubli
merci madame que je n'ai plus de madame
david huy rapidement parce que j'ai bien
entendu madame la ministre nous parler
de données scientifiques mais je rejoins
la question non le question décidément
le questionnement de catherine génisson
sûr
les données scientifiques qui disent 15
ans plutôt que 10 à madame la ministre
nous dit y'a rien scientifiquement
prouvée pour dix ans mais alors du coup
quelles sont les données scientifiques
pour 15 ans donc je meurs je me réjouis
de l'avis favorable de la ministre pour
les mineures je pense que c'est déjà
quelque chose d'important et
d'intéressant pour l'adoption de cet
article mais vraiment je regretterais
que nous n'arrivions pas à trouver une
avancée à l'issue de nos travaux ici à
l'assemblée concernant ce délai et
concernant le questionnaire aussi
j'entends bien les réserves enfin il
les arguments énoncés par la ministre
mais si le questionnaire reste ambigu
s'il continue à poser des questions qui
font que ce droit à l'oubli l'oubli ne
devient pas un véritable droit à l'oubli
eh bien je crois qu'on passerait quand
même un petit peu à côté de ce que nous
avons ensemble envie de faire c'est à
dire l'obtention d'un véritable droit à
l'oubli pour ces personnes c'est notre
collègue françoise laborde qu'il le
disait très bien quand elle parlait de
double peine
en effet il ya des personnes malades et
à des personnes après la maladie et
après la maladie il continue à être
pénalisés donc cette double peine doit
s'arrêter
merci madame la vie de madame la
ministre je ne reviens pas sur
l'ensemble des questionnements je
voudrais indiquer de deux points en
réponse aux interpellations en
particulier de madame génisson et je
peux dire que je suis un peu désolé de
de faire référence à de tels termes mais
parce que nous parlons de devis de
maladie de deux malades pardon mais l'un
cassé l'inca qui définit la durée
excusez moi j'ai un chat dans la gorge
oh vous êtes gentil monsieur bah oui bon
je vous crois mais je vais aller faire
un test de dépistage
mais bon la durée de 15 ans elle a été
fixée par des données produites par
l'inca dans le cadre du groupe de
travail relatif au droit à l'oubli et il
s'agit et c'est là où je voulais dire je
m'excuse employer ce terme mais ce sont
des données statistiques et la lca
scientifiquement nous ne pouvons
travailler qu'à partir de cela cela ne
veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas des
personnes qui seront dé facto guéri au
bout de 5 ans 10 ans 12 ans avant 15 ans
donc ça c'est la réponse que je vous
fais ces travaux là ils ont été
apportées par l'inca dans le cadre du
groupe mis en place pour travailler au
droit à l'oubli
mais j'ajoute tout de suite que
parallèlement à tout cela
l'inca s'est engagé dans la définition
de grille et va procéder à des
évaluations de ces risques statistiques
de rechute ou de ses champs statistiques
de guérison pour les différents cancers
et donc dès la fin assez rapidement il y
aura les premières grilles donc il n'est
pas du tout impossible
il est même plus que possible que pour
certains cancers
la durée limite de 15 ans soit abaissée
c'est à dire que l'inca commence par
travailler sur certains cancers en se
disant la statistiquement on voit bien
que les taux de guérison sont plus élevé
ou très élevé rapidement confirmables je
ne peux pas vous dire sur quels types de
cancers travail
l'inca quels seront les premières
grilles qui vont sortir mais l'idée
c'est bien que quinze ans c'est le délai
maximal et que en réalité au bout d'un
certain temps on se retrouve avec une
grille avec un ensemble de gris et des
délais différenciée selon les cancers
concernant voilà ce que je voulais
apporter comme élément de réponse
merci madame la ministre la parole à
monsieur barbier pour explication de
vote
merci mme présidente le miz chers
collègues je crois que malheureusement
en matière de cancérologie
on peut pas dire à une personne vous
êtes définitivement guéri ça n'existe
pas on peut procéder que par
statistiques par pathologie par groupes
d'âge et cetera mais à aucun moment
personne ne peut dire alors bien entendu
les chances de guérison définitive
augmente au fur et à mesure des années
mais dans ce domaine ça ne peut être
qu'une analyse statistique comme vient
de le souligner madame le ministre
je crois que ces quinquas a fixé à 15
ans c'est à partir de moyenne qui sont
calculées qui varie énormément en
matière de pathologie on sait très bien
que le taux de survie des cancers du
poumon très inférieurs à certains types
de cancer je crois que là il faut faire
confiance parce que qu'est ce qu'on
risque on risque de voir cette
convention repoussé par les signataires
si on leur impose un chiffre qui soit
trop bas alors peut-être que dans
quelques années on pourra évoluer mais
dans l'état actuel on procède par
statistiques c'est comme ça la deuxième
chose pour le patro intervenir
certaines certains ont déposé des
amendements pour ramener le problème de
15 ans à 18 ans 18 ans c'est l'âge
civile la majorité civile c'est pas la
majorité
c'est pas la majorité adultes à tel
point que dans les services de médecine
la pédiatrie s'arrête à 15 ans on est
admis en pédiatrie jusqu'à 15 ans après
quinze ans on passe dans les services à
lui et ça c'est pas totalement anodin
parce que compte tenu de ce délai de 5
ans qui réclamait de vacuité enfin de
l'absence de signes pour pouvoir dire
que la personne est guéri ça peut
s'appliquer pour les cancers de l'enfant
mais que par contre compte tenu d'un
certain abaissement de l'âge de
de l'abaissement de la des enfants on a
des cancers de l'adolescent qui
malheureusement sont très évolutif et je
pense que si on a proposé dans ces
conventions l'âge de 15 ans elle a aussi
c'est un âge qui est un âge qui est
déterminer scientifiquement
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'âge civile la
majorité 18 ans moi je pense qu'il faut
conserver cet âge de 15 ans peut-être
dans quelques années pouvoir le faire
évoluer
merci madame arcens mais aussi le
présent il vous est demandé la parole
mais j'ai plusieurs demandes vous à la
fin je son prix à les y prenait la
parole dans c'était pour une petite
explication de vote la présidente et
pour répondre un petit peu alain
vasselle c'est vrai que
quand nous avons examiné l'ensemble des
amendements lancre de la convention
était à peine sèche on avait quand même
une expérience assez grande déjà puisque
je vous rappelle quand même que les
premières conventions entre l'état et
les assureurs et les associations de
malades date de 1991 et ça concernait
les patients séropositifs à l'époque du
vih les premières conventions pour
toutes les maladies des pathologies date
de 2001
et je voulais intervenir sur deux petits
sujets sains pour rendre hommage au
travail qui avait été fait à l'époque
par le sénat en 2008 dans le cadre d'un
rapport sur la race justement qui était
un pas extrêmement important et qui
donnait des orientations qui ont été
reprises par la suite y compris
d'ailleurs désormais datation qui sont
reprises dans le texte actuel sans que
obligatoirement il a été reprise
volontairement c'est le rapport de marie
thérèse hermange que marie thérèse
hermange avait fait à la commission des
affaires sociales au sénat en 2008 et
sur un texte que nous avions ensuite
voter ici dans cette enceinte ont joué
en or noir j'ai un petit peu avec daver
manche sur un sujet important d'autant
que dans le cadre de cette fois on a
souvent sans jamais la cité beaucoup
parlé de ses interventions sur d'autres
sujets dont je reviendrai par la suite
et puis dire que dans la mesure où nous
n'avions pas l'ensemble des éléments
avec l'ong d'aidé pas encore sèche et
dans dans les orientations qui sont les
miennes au point de vue d'une ancienneté
médicale je vous inviterai quand même à
suivre les avis du gouvernement
merci monsieur milan madame archambault
vous avez demandé la parole
nous voterons un certain nombre de ces
deux amendements tout en ayant bien
conscience qu'il reste des incertitudes
scientifiques
c'est vrai mais le droit à l'oubli a été
introduit dans cette loi c'est un
progrès
il me semble que sur un sujet qui est
aussi préoccupant par autant de deux
français il est bon que que le sénat
manifeste son intérêt ça sa
préoccupation forte et il me semble
c'est aussi la meilleure façon de de
soutenir tous ceux qui cherchent et qui
se battent dans ce sens si monsieur
denis pour explication de vote
binyam la présidente madame la ministre
mais chaque collège madame la ministre
sur ce sujet difficile et sensible
je veux dire que vous avez été
totalement convaincante
vous avez bien montrer que le point de
départ ce sont des données statistiques
ces données statistiques elles sont
fixées par l'inca elles ne sont pas
fixés façon définitive
elles permettent d'établir des grilles
qui elles mêmes vont évoluer avec le
temps et notre souci donc est tout
simplement dans l'avenir sera de
vérifier que la convention évolue en
fonction de ses grilles au vu de ces
éléments et je parle pour ma collègue
catherine génisson et pour moi-même nous
nous rangerons donc à l'avis du
gouvernement et dont catherine génisson
et moi même nous ne voterons pas les
amendements à partir du numéro 137
jusqu'au 935 et par contre donc nous
voterons les amendements à partir du
numéro 139 jusqu'au numéro 937 merci je
n'ai plus de demandes d'explications de
vote je n'en vois pas je vais donc
mettre aux voix
ces amendements dont 137 rectifié bis
149 je voulais rappelle 608 rectifié bis
820 891 ray
si fier et 935 avec un avis de sagesse
de la commission et un avis défavorable
du gouvernement
je vais mettre aux voix qui est pour moi
je voudrais bien levé la main pour que
je puisse compter
qui est contre
pas
qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés le 138
rectifié by six ans je parle sous
couvert de la commission 1 609 rectifié
1836 tombe mais bien d'accord le 139
rectifié terre 566 610 rectifié 1892
rectifié 937 tombe le 140 rectifié terre
le 6 ans rectifié bis le 938 tombe le
141 rectifié bis le 939 tombe à la joue
pas trop vite le 821 tombe
il nous reste les trois amendements
identiques 143 rectifié terre 893
rectifié 1941
on est bien d'accord j'ai pas demain je
n'ai pas de réaction donc a priori la
bande la commission est bien d'accord je
vais des prêtres ou voir ces amendements
je n'ai pas de demandes d'explications
de vote je n'en vois pas
je rappelle l'avis de la commission
sagesse à vis du gouvernement
défavorable je mets aux voix ces
amendements qui est pour